and today I will have the honor
to be received by his majesty the king
it will be a truly special moment
for me
for our country
and in particular because I will convey
to him from all the
all the ukrainians the wars of gratitude
for the support he has Majesty showed to
them when he was still the Prince of
Wales
and I also intend to tell him something
that is I think that is very very
important not only for the future of
Ukraine but also for the future of
Europe in Britain
in Britain the king
is a near Force pilot
and in Ukraine today
every year Force pilate is a king
for us just just for us
for our families
because there are so few
they are so precious that we the
Servants of our Kings
do everything possible and impossible to
make the world provide us with modern
planes
to empower and protect pilots who will
be protecting us
and I am proud of our Air Force
and I brought a present
from them
to you Great Britain
yes please open place
yes
to the speaker yes speaker
[Applause]
it's it's I I
will explain is the helmet of her real
Ukrainian pilot he is one of our most
successful
Aces and he's one of our Kings
and the writing on the helmet reads
we have freedom give us Wings to protect
it
[Applause]
I trust I trust this symbol will help us
for our next coalition
Coalition of the planes and I appeal to
you and the world was simple and yet
most important words
combat aircrafts for Ukraine wings for
freedom
[Applause]
Great Britain you and us both
struggle for peace but instead of we are
forced to face the range that seeks to
deprive us of peace and everything else
that is valuable in life unfortunately
it is in human nature to allow evil
main sure
it then stands up against humanity
it then destroys
and kills it launches aggressions and
breaks people's lives you and us have
already fought together again against
such evil
you and us already
have the experience of defeating the
evil that is generated by human nature
I'm not saying there will be there will
be no more Wars after the war ends no it
is impossible to completely erase evil
from Human Nature
yet it is in our power to guarantee with
words and deeds that the light side of
human nature will prevail
beside you and us share and this stands
above anything else
thank you
for your attention
for your support
and living
a British Parliament two years ago I
thanked you
for delicious English tea
and I will be living
the parliament today
thanking all of you in advance
for powerful English planes
[Applause]